le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
être dans l'impasse une situation que
connaissent beaucoup de jeunes
réunionnais quand il s'agit d'emplois
c'est pour cela que le département veut
les aider à intégrer le monde du travail
depuis 2011 l' académie des dalons
propose un accompagnement à ces jeunes
en manque de repères et loïc fait partie
des élèves de cette promotion il a
rejoint l'établissement du bernica à
saint paul
[Musique]
groupe qui va passer on est là les
visages sont fermés
à quelques minutes du lever de rideau
les acteurs se concentre au bernica l'
académie des dalons ouvre ses portes
pour un spectacle entièrement écrit par
sa 14e promotion
le chikungunya
la leptospirose ou encore le sida des
sujets graves mais traitée avec humour
par les jeunes élèves sous forme de
sketches de courts métrages ou encore de
rap amoureux ou pas aux tâches doit pour
les élèves c'est une première parmi eux
et loïc 23 ans après trois mois
d'internât il a déjà pratiqué de
nombreuses activités avec ses camarades
le fil conducteur c'est la mise en
situation
l'objectif c'est que les personnes
soient le moins possible situation on
est et qui permettent aux situations
l'académie des dalons a été créé en 2011
par le département
sa mission conseiller et accompagner les
jeunes réunionnais en difficultés
sociales et professionnelles
c'est aussi la possibilité pour les gens
de s'approprier des valeurs des valeurs
qui sont souvent présentes chez elle
mais qu'ils ont pas eu l'occasion
d'expérimenter hypothèse qui est
derrière c'est on va on va être mieux
dans sa vie personnelle et
professionnelle
si déjà
les références sur lesquelles on ne
construit si on les a alimenté sur les à
consolider une aide bienvenue pour et
loïc qui a connu plusieurs mois
d'inactivité regarde les autres à venir
rien n'avance pas au bureau après rien
n'est sûr pour mémé tu as vu une comédie
ici apprennent à nous adroit respecter
les uns les autres
et ben voilà il s'élève à - beaucoup en
fait après trois mois d'internât et loïc
va effectuer neuf mois de service
civique
il a choisi l'association kolkhoze une
structure spécialisée dans l'audiovisuel
c'est nous fait des montages vidéos ont
filmé pour et loïc c'est une vraie
découverte
après avoir participé au spectacle de
l'académie il a pris goût aux techniques
de l'audiovisuel
c'est nouveau mais en même temps c'est
excitant c'est parce que je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qu'il y aura demain comment
sera fait il mesure les tournages de
aller compliquée mais
franchement laid
le jeune stagiaire est formé par
josélito un ancien dalons de l'académie
maintenant salariés de l'association
maintenant je suis formateur je suis
jeune et maintenant je fais partie de
ces personnes qui vont quand on a vu que
le ca qu il était intéressé par le
visuel donc voilà c'est fallu à proposer
justement le vénère avec nos ports
découvrir et approfondir ses
connaissances entre l'aîné et son cadet
la transmission est en cours j'espère à
la fin qu'on va pouvoir voir un petit
diplôme ni expérience réussie pour et
loïc le jeune homme est désormais plus
sûr de lui et de ses capacités
demande un gamin comme avant parce
qu'avant d'être quand même normal mais
aujourd'hui mais représentait le conseil
général d du département la baie de
manille warm comme si voilà mal à ce
point mais en plus j'ai pris ma seconde
que seulement voilà dans des fois l'a
fait écouter un peso camarades
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'académie des dalons a été créé en 2011
par le département
son objectif aider les jeunes
réunionnais à s'insérer socialement et
professionnellement l'académie s'adresse
aux jeunes âgés de 18 à 25 ans elle leur
propose un accompagnement d'un an dont
trois mois d'internât et 9 mois de
service civique
depuis sa création elle a accompagné
près de 300 jeunes réunionnais pour plus
d'information vous pouvez consulter le
site de l'académie au www.cegedim.fr
slash dalons ou appeler le numéro vert 0
800 1 801 000
[Musique]